and routing are iterative processes and they assign a virtual Cubit to your circuit on the physical Cubit on the
hardware you can do this by hand but there are also Tools in kcit which can make recommendations for the physical
Cubit layout based on approximate error rates next we can compose sequences of one cubit Gates acting on the same Cubit
into single Gates and we can also sometimes get rid of unnecessary Gates or combinations of gates for example
some combinations of gates can be reduced to simpler combinations and sometimes combinations of gates even
equate to just a simple identity operator so we can simply eliminate them you can do this automatically using the
kkit transpiler or you can do it manually on a gate bygate basis if you have a good reason to do so and you want
more control once we've improved the circuit layout routing and gate counts either by hand or by using the kuit transpiler we
usually want to visualize our circuit to make sure that the timing of all the gates makes sense there is an argument that you can flag in the transpiler to
visualize the timeline of your circuit and make sure that everything is lined up the way that you would expect now let's talk about error
suppression error suppression refers to various techniques that transform a C during compilation to minimize errors
it's different from error mitigation which takes place after the circuit has already been run and we'll come to that shortly the two most common forms of
error suppression that we take advantage of are dynamical decoupling and poly twirling there is going to be some
technical details here but you can always refer back to this later so the first dynamical decoupling is used to
effectively cancel out some of the noise affecting the Cubit by applying a series of gates that together amount to the
identity operation like XX sequences and whose net effect is to approximately cancel out the noise channels affecting
the cubid poly twirling is a way of inserting random gates to simplify the average noise the randomness helps
prevent the effects from different errors from building up as fast and also makes the noise easier to characterize
now this method also forms the basis of an error mitigation technique and we're going to be discussing that later
again there's a lot of information here and don't worry if it doesn't all SN in immediately luckily a lot of this can be done automatically using the kcit
transpiler transpilation can be tricky though but the transpilation is such a crucial step to achieve utility at scale
that it requires a lot of trial and error in order to be mastered and obtained the best results now I want to take a brief
interlude to discuss the kiskat transpiler and its capabilities a bit more I'll do this at a very high level and we'll get into the details and see
some examples later on in general transpilation is the process of rewriting a given input circuit to match
the topology and specific Quantum device and optimize the circuit for execution and resilience against noise it also
rewrites a given circuit into the basis Gates of that specific Quantum processor you have selected to use kkit has four
built-in transpilation pipelines and unless you're already familiar with Quantum circuit optimization I definitely recommend using one of those
built-in pipelines by default the transpiler includes these six steps initialization
layout routing translation optimization and scheduling now initialization refers to
any initial pass that is required before we start embedding the circuit onto the back end this typically involves
unrolling custom instructions and converting the circuit into just one and two Cubit Gates the layout stage applies
a layout mapping the virtual cubits in the circuit to the physical cubits on a back end routing runs after a layout has
been applied and injects Gates such as swap Gates into the original circuit to make it compatible with the backend's
connectivity the fourth stage is translation in this stage the gates in the circuit are translated to the Target
backends basis set next is optimization this stage runs the main optimization
Loop repeatedly until a condition such as reaching a certain Target depth is met we have four different optimization
levels that we are able to choose from last is scheduling this stage is for any hardware aware scheduling passes at a
high level scheduling can be thought of as inserting delays into the circuit to account for any idle time on the cubits
between the execution of instructions so like I said there are four optimization levels ranging from 0 to three where
higher optimization levels take more time and computational effort but you might end up with a better circuit
optimization level zero is intended for device characterization experiments and as such only Maps the input circuit to
the constraints of the target backend it doesn't perform any optimization optimization level three
spends the most effort to optimize the circuit however as many of the optimization techniques in the
transpiler are based on heris sixs spending more computational effort doesn't always result in an improvement
in the quality of the output circuit if this is of further interest please check out the transpiler pages in the kisc
documentation linked below now we are ready to discuss the actual execution of a Quantum circuit
the kcit runtime Primitives provide an interface to IBM Quantum hardware and they also abstract away error
suppression and mitigation from the user the sampler primitive Returns the Quasi probability distribution or counts
representing the likelihood of measuring certain bit strings zeros and ones the estimator primitive returns expectation
values of observables corresponding to physical quantities so in a little bit more detail the sampler runs the circuit
multiple times on a Quantum device performing measurements on each run and constructing the probability
distribution from recovering those bit strings the more runs or shots it performs the more accurate the results
will be but this requires more time and the Quantum Resources required to run that specifically it calculates the
probability of obtaining each possible standard basis state by measuring the state prepared by the circuit kiskis
estimator uses a complex algebraic process to estimate the expectation value on a real Quantum device by
breaking down the observable into a combination of other observables that have known igen bases and running under
the hood of The Primitives are the techniques called error mitigation error mitigation is an umbrella term for all of this and it
basically refers to the techniques that allow us to reduce circuit Errors By modeling the device noise at the time of
execution typically this results in Quantum pre-processing overhead related to the model training and classical
post-processing overhead to mitigate errors in the Raw results by using a generated model but in exchange for this
overhead we're able to get much more accurate results there are multiple techniques that we can Implement for